hello welcome to my kitchen my name is
andrew you might recognize me from the
show
worth it where i'm usually tasting foods
at different price points with my pals
steven and adam today i'm attempting to
recreate one of my favorite things
i ever had on worth it the lychee and
grape smoothie
from spoon by h this was in our korean
soups episode
at spoon by h everything is
stunning from the classic korean dishes
the desserts to the drinks
everything has this sculptural flourish
to it that is so enticing you're afraid
to consume before consuming it but then
once you try it you realize it's so much
more
than it even was in just your eyes this
fits into something that i'm really
curious in which is
the fundamentals of why something tastes
good
holy sh with this lychee and grape
smoothie i'm interested in how
its visual presentation enhances your
experience in eating it so to start off
i'm speaking with yoon
from spoon by h to learn more about how
this drink is made
hey yoon it's nice to see you oh hi
it's funny that when i first asked you
about this smoothie you said
it was really simple but then i'm
looking at the steps there's whipped
cream
then you're stacking grapes there's
flowers and then even there's the little
piece of paper that says spoon by age
which to me is like
a lot of effort for one drink every time
we eat something we
eat it with our eye first right i want
to make
everyone like happy to give them special
experience
to me it's very unique to find a cafe
like yours where
the drinks are given as much attention
as the desserts
it's a like a little different culture
in korea you know
they do everything in one place in
united states
you know boba place they do this boba
but when you go to korea
and get like brunch boba milk tea waffle
like all together
doing the grape stacking i think that's
going to be the most difficult part for
me
do you have any advice um it's like a
game you know
xanga right jenga so if it's your first
time you know make
your smoothie like more icy because you
know when you work your
grape part if it's too long smoothie is
going to be melt the whipped cream parts
it's gonna be gonna sink down right oh
yeah yeah
so you have to do it really quickly
thank you so much for chatting with me
i'm gonna
go and get started on making this
smoothie thank you thank you
i'm so excited
we got our ingredients and the first
thing we're going to do today
is prepare an infused milk and a simple
syrup that will be
in the smoothie which we'll make
tomorrow first off let's look at a
lychee i know that some people say
lychee some people say
lychee i don't think that there's a
wrong way to say it kind of like a berry
looking thing
oh can you hear that
very like dry paper type of exterior but
then the inside
is this beautiful translucent white
flesh
the smell is very melony
very unique flavor kind of like rose
water
not too dissimilar from a grape actually
in fact you could kind of
close your eyes and think that you were
eating a grape with a flower petal
wrapped around it
for our grapes we're just using green
grapes i know what a grape tastes like
but
for the side by side it's very curious
you know the lychee almost tastes like
the bottom half of what the grape tastes
like
a grape and a lychee are the same note
but the grape is a high note and the
lychee is a base note to then put those
together
and kind of represent the same tonal
similarity
across a range
[Music]
grapes so pretty much what we're going
to do is start by
slicing a bunch of grapes put them in
this jar
cover with milk you know what's
interesting about grapes despite being
so juicy
they also kind of make me thirsty i
think that's called astringency
and it's like the same thing that
happens with a wine that makes your
mouth pucker
i guess i'm gonna pour a bunch of milk
on top of these grapes now
this feels so wrong to me for some
reason
but i guess it's not that strong and
this is probably how flavors of ice
cream
are made this feels like something i
would do as a kid and then get yelled at
by my mom for doing but
hey it's gourmet mom deal with it so
there's actually also a
secret ingredient for this step and are
you also putting the
in there oh
okay we don't have to put that in you
made me promise i wouldn't say so
you're just gonna have to deal with not
knowing what i'm doing to this milk now
okay so next up we're gonna be making a
simple syrup with lychee and so i'm
going to start by
pitting a bunch of lychee okay welcome
to the stove
area for yoon syrup half raw sugar half
agave
an equal proportion of water and
the lychee and now we wait for it to
boil the hot lychee has taken on kind of
like a roasted
chestnut scent to it okay the syrup is
cooled down
and now we're just going to strain it
we're also going to take the lychee that
we boiled and freeze it syrup will go in
the fridge
and tomorrow we can make a smoothie
so i remember from the soup video one of
the most impressive features
this tiny little spoon by h paper logo
so i'm going to make my own little logo
i'm not going to call it spoon by h
because
i don't think my version is going to
live up to theirs so i'm going to give
it
spoon by a maybe i should do it a couple
times
big top part of the s that's important
penmanship is a highly underrated skill
i think i can just use the tip
of my sharpest knife
i think that'll work next step is to
portion some more fruit before we get to
the blending stage does this look like
my eyeballs
[Music]
when you cook by yourself weird things
happen just a fact of life these
containers are
uh leftover from spoon by itch takeout
the takeout out
amazing highly recommend we did a video
about it
i now also need to slice grapes
for the decoration of the smoothies
start with just one grape at a time i
guess
this is probably the most crazy aspect
i'm starting to think about the number
of
individual cuts for your average sized
grape it's like one
two three i need maybe 10 to 20 grapes
just for the top so now you're looking
at
30 individual cuts for one drink
okay so it's time to start actually
making a smoothie
handful of grapes our infused milk
smells like milk
mmm a sweet melon
nature to it we have our lychee syrup
from yesterday
[Music]
um it does have like a warm
sweet flavor the way that maple syrup
does for example
sure we also have the frozen leftover
lychee from that syrup
and then just a few fresh lychee so this
isn't in yun's recipe but
something that i have to do in my
kitchen because i don't have the most
powerful blender
i've learned to pre-break my ice
but it's okay because i have this
suspiciously thick spoon
this is not what you does at the
restaurant
i'm gonna break a couple eggs to make an
omelette time to blend
sounds like i'm changing tires and right
now
i just need to taste this to make sure i
got the proportions right
oh yeah let's talk about my glass
options
this is the closest thing i could find
this is a lot smaller i know but it's
still kind of that
thicker tulip shape working quickly now
because this is icy
most of the volume a whipped cream cone
for the grapes to sit on
if you can tell i'm kind of freaking
nervous right now because this thing is
melting i
don't i can't imagine doing this in the
restaurant setting
to order now i'm gonna start overlapping
ooh but now i need smaller grapes what
you can't just use
any slice that you sell
so right off the bat i understand that
it looks way less impressive
on a smaller scale which is crazy
because the actual
smoothie is larger and has more grapes
oh it's melting so much okay one other
decorative element which is flowers i'm
just going to use
individual petals when we had it in the
soup episode
yoon's smoothie features these white
flowers it's a seasonal thing so it's
not always going to be those flowers
my cream is really melting i hate
everything about this
yoon was like this recipe is too easy i
don't know why you want to do this
recipe
come on this is easy i'm going to take
one choice grape make an incision just
in the top
insert my spoon by a
okay there's my melty smoothie
there's my melty smoothie okay i'm gonna
make this smoothie again
here's what we do this time to try to
optimize for the circumstances i'm
making it in
slice my grapes thinner since i'm
dealing with a smaller wine glass
i want all of the features to be a
little bit smaller
pre-select my flower petals arrange them
by size and color so that there's
a little down time in the assembly phase
as possible
smoothie whipped cream
grapes much tighter pattern
i don't know if working faster really
did
smoothie a whole lot of favors now for
my capstone
grape i think if i shoot it from some
angles i can trick you into thinking it
looks kind of good
i am melting and the smoothie is melting
still delicious yeah it's kind of like a
similar enjoyment
to having a milkshake but without all
the heaviness
of a milkshake i think we all know how i
did it
didn't really come out as visually
stunning as it does at spoon by age
i think there's something very unique
about putting a ton of effort
into one first impression moment
with food i feel like i've just gotten a
door
crack view into the amount of stuff that
they do at spoon by h
and it is it's mind-blowing and if you
want an actually well-made smoothie
as well as some delicious desserts and
amazing savory food please visit them
it's truly one of the best restaurants
in los angeles
yeah i mean a milkshake will just put
you to
bed not this though
you